[Musik]
herr liebe formel-1-fans das qualifying
in monaco ist in der regel ein
besonderes spektakel
und so war es auch diesmal wieder wenn
auch nicht unbedingt mit einem
überraschenden ausgang lewis hamilton
hat sich die pole position gesichert vor
walter roboters und das relativ deutlich
im grunde so wie es in der verlaufenden
saison stattgefunden hat mit einem
großem vorsprung diesmal aber vor dem
dritten verstappen im red bull und dann
erst mit großem abstand acht
zehntelsekunden sebastian vettel das
bedeutet es sieht schwer danach aus dass
die doppel erfolgsserie von mercedes
bestand hat auch im rennen sie wissen in
monaco ist das überholen schwierig wenn
es also keine großen zwischenfälle gibt
dann kann man davon ausgehen dass
mercedes auch im sechsten versuch
gewinnen wird und vielleicht sogar mit
zwei fahrern ganz vorne stehen wollen
trotzdem gab es ein spektakel ein selbst
inszeniertes bei ferrari zunächst einmal
weil vettel im dritten training
ausgerutscht waren wenn man das so sagen
darf wegen eines bremsfehlers in der
ersten kurve geradeaus ging der
frontflügel zerstört die linke
radaufhängung kaputt da musste er
zuschauen das ist bitter in monaco denn
mit jeder runde versucht man sich im
dritten training an das tempo zu
gewöhnen es langsam zu steigern die nähe
der leitplanken das wissen sie alle sehr
wichtig ein kleiner fehler und wirklich
ein zwei zentimeter rechts oder links
und schon geht's dahin
deshalb hatte vettel zu beginn des
qualifyings probleme
er hat sich dann aber durchgebissen und
schaffte dann im ersten versuch im
ersten durchgang im allerletzten moment
noch sogar eine bestzeit
es ging ein raunen durch das
pressezentrum aber das vermischte sich
ein bisschen denn in dem moment stellten
die kollegen ich also auch fest dass
vettel den anderen ferrari fahrer
aus dem rennen geworfen hatte und den
nur 16 geworden ist und deshalb nicht
mehr weiter verhandelt was war passiert
geklagt hatte eigentlich eine
ordentliche zeit hingelegt war aber der
box geblieben weil die ingenieure
glaubten diese zeit würde reichen um in
die zweite runde zu kommen
sie wollten einen satz reifen sparen und
das ging schief clark klagte darüber
fragte nach wie kann das passieren
vettel verteidigt ein bisschen die
strategie des teams binotto
der teamchef schickte das hinzu und
sagte auch ja so etwas kann passieren
das darf natürlich nicht passieren
es ist aber leider auffällig dass
ferrari diese fehler häufiger macht als
mercedes ein wirkliches problem aber
wurde dadurch ein bisschen kaschiert das
ist die behandlung der reifen ferrari
hat immer noch keinen weg gefunden wie
es auf höhe von mercedes kommen will
sie kriegen immer noch die vorderreifen
nicht schnell genug war und deswegen hat
der vettel auch kein vertrauen in monaco
und wenn man kein vertrauen hatte der
markt dann reicht es nicht für den ganz
vorderen platz und sollte das so
weitergehen dann fürchte ich wird die
formel 1 saison in den nächsten zwei
drei rennen entschieden werden so weit
dass monaco
[Musik]